welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
accelerating rapid test development for
covid19
through manufacturing scale up and open
collaboration
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
david wilson
commercial director of diagnostics at
evacta life sciences
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab
at the top of your screen now if any
questions arise during the presentation
we want to encourage you to submit them
in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming david
wilson i will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome david
thank you for that introduction today
i'm going to talk about
the rapid development of covert 19 rapid
diagnostics
and specifically accelerating the rapid
test development
and manufacturing scale up through open
collaboration
i'd just like to start with a review of
the
uh of the webinar um which is captured
in the
abstract to the webinar as it pulls out
some of the key themes
i would like to address in today's
webinar
uh the covert 19 pandemic has brought
unprecedented challenges these are
unique challenges
to the in vitro diagnostics industry and
in turn
that provides both unique opportunities
to demonstrate the value of diagnostic
testing and a strong diagnostics
industry
but at the same time unique challenges
which i will address and they include
accelerated development
of tests the significant
scale-up of manufacturing to meet
unprecedented demand
and how this is being managed by the
industry
through open pre-competitive
collaboration
with multiple stakeholders not just
amongst industry players
but also other stakeholders such as
governments
supply chain regulatory agencies funding
bodies etc
and ultimately why the diagnostics
industry will
emerge from this a much stronger
industry
and this will be one of the enduring
legacies of the pandemic
so i will address why this is both an
opportunity
what the key challenges are how the
industry is rising to those challenges
and the legacy of this in terms of the
strength of the diagnostics industry
and the value of the industry as
perceived by
governments
so starting with why this is a unique
opportunity
uh ivds for a long time certainly in
my lifetime working in the industry
which is now nearly 30 years
ivds have traditionally been undervalued
by healthcare systems
they really sat in the shadow of
therapeutics
and um and other med tech
markets and that's despite
their their value to uh to health care
systems
however the covert 19 pandemic
highlights the the leading roles that
ivds can play
in overcoming global health challenges
and now why the development of a
stronger diagnostics capability
has become a strategic priority for many
governments
across the world i will talk a lot
from the perspective of the uk which is
where i'm based
but i think the messages apply um
to other countries as well
so looking at why high ivds are
undervalued by healthcare systems
you know there is the uh statistic which
is
you know has been around for a while
that
diagnostic decisions or diagnostic tests
rather
um you know influence seventy percent of
clinical decisions
yet only less than
one percent of health care budgets
um are dedicated to the use of
new and innovative uh diagnostic
products
and you could question why that is
and that is one of the
main reasons why we feel
in the diagnostics industry that that
ivds are significantly undervalued
there's a famous quote by alan mario
who's the chairman of the maria
foundation which kind of captured it
without a diagnosis
medicine is blind so you would think
that the use of diagnostics and the
value of diagnostics
would be perceived much higher than it
currently is
and this this slide i know it's a busy
slide
this is data from uh the e
the main the top 15 european
um ivd markets and you
might be able to see in the
third sorry second column to the right
to the end this is the s the
um the ibd market as a percentage
of the total healthcare spend
and you will see in in all all in most
cases
um it's less than one percent and the
average for the
total eu 15 is not 0.6 percent
and then if you look at the last column
and this is the uh the
the spend on diagnostics per capita
and the average for the eu 15 is
you know just short of 23 euros
per person and in the uk
which in the uk is the second largest
economy
in europe uh second largest gdp
and um the uh diagnostic spend per
capita
is the lowest at just under 15 euros per
person
so why is this why are ivds undervalued
by healthcare systems
well there are lots of reasons they
probably vary from country to country
but one key one
is the central one on this slide is it
really a lack of understanding
of how the use of ivds can lead to a
more effective
and rapid and accurate diagnosis which
enables you to tailor
patient care in other words you can
manage
patients appropriately send them down
the right clinical pathways
and when care is being commissioned or
diagnostic tests being commissioned the
benefits of diagnostics
are either misunderstood or not
considered at all
but with the advent now of the covet 19
pandemic
that's changing that perception of the
value of the ivd
of ivds in general and the industry in
particular is changing
and we probably all remember the the
world health organizations mantra
back when the pandemic started to test
test test
the the who um you know believes that
testing
in combination with isolation and
contact tracing is the backbone of the
or should be the backbone
of the global response to the covet 19
pandemic
and without the testing um
you know the head of the who says it's
it's not possible to fight a fire
blindfolded
almost you know um similar to alan
maria's quote
without diagnosis medicine is blind
so it's become you know well accepted
now that testing
for stars cov2 and screening for
covered 19 antibodies is widely
acknowledged or widely acknowledged as
the key tools
to manage both the human and economic
impact
of the global coronavirus pandemic and
it's the ability to test and test at
scale
in combination with access to a vaccine
which are really the key tools to
enabling society
to return to normal at some point in the
future
and it's interesting now as well that
one output of this is that diagnostic
testing
has become part of the national
conversation and you regularly hear
um on mainstream media on television
and in newspapers uh discussions around
concepts
such as test sensitivity specificity
and predictive values and i've provided
a link here to just one such
article in a uk national newspaper
and i think this is indicative of how
mainstream
uh uh diagnostics has become
um um and because of its role
key role in in tackling the uh the
covert 19
pandemic and long may that last so you
can see diagnostics is starting to
emerge from the shadows
of therapeutics and other med tech
and it's also highlighted the integral
value of diagnostics
to a well-managed health and care system
interestingly the uk government
acknowledged that the uk
went into the pandemic with a shortfall
in testing capacity and capability and
that was due to
a lack of investment in diagnostics
compared to other countries and we've
even heard some
government advisors say that the uk had
no home-based diagnostics industry
of any note well that's absolutely not
true
but it does illustrate how
you know how invisible the diagnostics
industry has been
and how a lack of investment in the
industry
has had an impact on the country's
ability to respond quickly
compared to other countries um such as
germany for example
which is generally acknowledged to have
responded better
to the pandemic because it was able to
scale up testing much more rapidly
than than other countries so i think
that's that's certainly in the uk that's
been recognized
and one one output of that is the fact
that the government has
stated that they want the uk diagnostics
industry
to come out of this much stronger and
ready to respond much more quickly
the next hopefully there won't be one
but it's likely there will be
responding more quickly to the to the
next pandemic
so that's that's the opportunity um
let's now look at some of the challenges
some of the key challenges um are
the requirement to develop
products very quickly and so
the requirement for a very rapid
compressed product development timeline
um and at the same time to deliver
effective and safe products
the pandemic was you know
acknowledged um in december 2019
the first tests where development
started
in early in january 2020
um and some of those tests were
developed and reached the market in time
to help fight the
first wave of the pandemic you know so
within six months
um but not all and now very largely most
countries are into the second wave
and some of those products are coming to
market
in time for the second wave
of the pandemic but that requires a
development time scale of a matter of a
few months
and as i'll go on to show later
typically these types of products can
take two to three years
and when they follow normal development
timelines so the challenge has been to
to go through that product development
timeline and develop a product which is
you know effective i.e it's accurate and
also safe
but do it a lot more quickly than um is
traditionally done
the second challenge is the the scale
of the demand and i'll talk a little bit
more about that in some more detail
but it's the requirement to scale up
manufacturing capacity manufacturing
capacity is is currently
nowhere near sufficient to meet demand
and there's not only the requirement to
scale that up but it's to scale it up
in orders of magnitude um higher than it
currently is
and quickly so again in a matter of
months
when typically these scale-up activities
can take
you know a year or more
and then finally the other challenge is
the supply chain it's not just about
manufacturing the tests it's all the
components that go into making that test
you know the plastics the buffers the
reagents
um they're all in demand
and the you know the lack of
availability of many of these components
is um is having an impact on the ability
to produce
the tests at the quantities and levels
required
so just looking at timelines i've just
on this slide outlined
a typical timeline and
and phases of development of a
diagnostic product through
you know from assay design through to
approval
and launch and normally this
this approach is taken um sequentially
and it's done for a reason because it's
the it's the best way to ensure that you
deliver
an effective and safe product usually
this takes two minimum of two to three
years
to go through this process and
under the pandemic uh you know it's it's
required to be compressed to within six
to nine months
so you can imagine if test development
initiates in january 2020
you know to get to get a product um on
the market
so that it can be used um in the
pandemic
this year means that you normally have
to compress those timelines
by a factor of two or three which is a a
very very
significant challenge and we'll talk a
little bit later about how that's been
addressed
okay next slide
okay looking at the the scale of the
manufacturing capacity scale up that's
required
i've just for one type of test which is
the
um antigen tests the lateral flow
antigen tests i just put some numbers
here
to give an indication of the demand
and the current manufacturing capacity
to show the size of the gap
um between the two so in the uk
as an example it's
the government has estimated in order to
reduce the r number most effectively
they should be able to test
between seven and eight percent of the
population every single day
and that would require roughly 5 million
tests per day
or 100 million tests per month and those
tests would come from
all the various uh types of tests that
are
you know being developed pcr tests
lateral flow tests
lamp tests and it's really the
combination of all of those
that would be required to meet that type
of or that level
of uh of testing on a daily basis
and in the uk that's called operation
moonshot
in the united states you know similar
estimates uh
estimates that a population about six
percent of the population
really needs to be tested every day and
that equates to about
20 million tests per day and i've
put a link in the in the slides there
with a link to
the source of that those particular
estimates
and then in the lower and middle income
countries you know the gates foundation
you know is looking to supply 500
million tests over the next
12 months and those will primarily be
the rapid lateral flow type tests
which can be supplied the only ones that
really could be supplied at that scale
and actually ultimately the the total
demand
could be the whole world population
tested frequently
so that you know calculates to many
billions
of tests that are required and these
tests
would be required at that scale in order
to
you know regularly test the whole
population so that you can pick up
quickly pick up um the most infectious
people
and therefore reduce the spread of the
virus
and the r number uh very effectively
so that's the size of the that's the
scale of the
of the um demand if we look at for
example in the uk what's the current
manufacturing capacity for lateral flow
tests
well at the moment it's only 500 sorry 5
million
per month so you can see the gap between
current capacity
and required demand and this is the
challenge the scale-up challenge which
is currently
um the industry is addressing in
collaboration with
with governments so is it
not only is the size of the scale up
significant you know
can you actually scale up by many orders
of magnitude in just three to four
months
is that actually possible
and one of the scale up challenges is
you know who's going to pay for it you
know if industry invests
in scaling up manufacturing and capacity
for a an opportunity which may not be
there in 12 months time
you know how is that going to be managed
how can companies be encouraged
to do that
and then as i mentioned the supply chain
supply chain constraints
um the manufacturing capacity for all
critical raw materials and i mean
all and all consumables is is
insufficient as well
so there's shortages of swabs of sample
collection devices
other plastic consumables antibodies
nitrocellulose strips everything
is in in short supply so the
manufacturing scale-up challenge is not
just for the tests themselves
it's for the whole supply chain in order
to
make enough material available so that
you can make the tests
so it is a very very significant
challenge
so what about the industry response so
i'd like to before i discuss this i'd
just like to
lay out that you know we are the the
pandemic has
has sort of set out a very very
different competitive environment now
for the ivd industry
you know as i've shown global demand far
exceeds
the combined global production capacity
and demand is on a scale that really
only a collective industry response
can address so markets can actually
accommodate
multiple and all test manufacturers and
in fact it requires
all and as many as possible
so everything that is produced will be
sold and it will be sold
quickly so this change in competitive
environment
really fosters increased collaboration
and innovation
so no longer are companies competing for
market share of a restricted market
um the market is is probably the largest
market that
the diagnostics industry will ever
experience
which is effectively the whole world
population tested
frequently so
there's no fighting for market share um
production and sorry um revenues
will be constrained more about how much
can be made
as opposed to how much share of a market
that a company can
can gain
so the accelerated development and time
to market requires collaboration with
governments
regulators funding bodies and national
health care systems
so the whole environment um actually
fosters
a different relationship between all the
stakeholders
which is a much more collaborative and
innovative approach
to solving this problem
just uh looking at the different types
of
tests you know in order to meet the
demand
that i mentioned it's really going to
require the contribution
from a lot of different test types and
all of them
together uh there are you know specific
tests
are suited for specific use cases or
settings and there's you know pcr for
example
is is a good test for detecting
infected patients so at-risk groups
because of its higher sensitivity and
specificity
whereas uh testing the the broader
population
to enable return to normal life
would require for example a lateral flow
test
because it can be produced at scale um
it can return a result quickly
and is relatively inexpensive
and that is a different use obviously
than the pcr
test and but both are required
to meet the demand because the demand is
multifaceted
and is based on different
settings different use cases that
require different solutions
so i've mentioned why it's not just
about one or two different
tests it requires all available tests
in order to meet demand
and industry is responding to that
through collaborations to
deploy all available technologies ip
and testing capacity i'll give three
examples
from my own company so avacta and the
detricks
are collaborating to develop a mass spec
based
sars cov2 test to utilize the
large installed base of moldy tough
instruments in clinical settings
so we are the vector we are not um we're
not mass spec
company at all adapts is we
we provide our uh very specific affirmer
protein binders
adept provides the mass spec platform
capability
and together we can we can develop a
test
which um is run on a
a type of instrument which is currently
utilized in clinical settings but not
at the moment contributing to testing
capacity
for at-risk groups so together by coming
together we can provide a test
which um then enables these instruments
to be brought into
the national testing program and
and contribute to that that particular
testing capacity
and we can only do that by working
together
avacta and sativa are also collaborating
to develop a rapid source curve 2
antigen test
again combining our highly specific
atheroma reagents
and saitiva's high performance
nitrocellulose strip technology
to provide a rapid frequent mass testing
solution
again combining capabilities and
technologies from two
organizations that can't actually
provide both
themselves and then finally our
affirmations are used
in other applications for example
testing wastewater
um and the for the development of a
breath test
for sars cough ii and that's work that's
been done by um
uk public company called deep verge
so those are just some examples of the
ability to combine
and collaborate to combine technologies
and
ip to develop tests which will then
increase the
testing capacity
so how are industry governments
regulatory bodies
funding healthcare systems collaborating
to support
accelerated development i've just
just drawn out some examples here from
the uk and the us
of initiatives which are
being set up and established to do just
that
so in the uk we have a program called
the condor program
which was set up with government
government as brought together
um hospitals universities
government-funded clinical research
bodies really to create a single route
to evaluate new diagnostic tests for
covert 19.
and and this is a capability that all
companies that are developing tests are
encouraged to use and should facilitate
access to clinical samples
and clinical validation so this was set
up to accelerate
that part of the development process
and it's expected that that program will
continue
post covered as an enduring asset
um for the uh for the uk diagnostics
industry
also the mhra which is the regulatory
body um in the uk
uh they are working very closely in
collaboration with with industry on the
development of the
target product profiles for the various
covert 19 tests
so you know typically industry is
consulted on the development of these
but
it's much more so at the moment um and
those target
product profiles are currently in
development some have already been
issued
some are to be issued and there's a very
very close
collaboration between the regulatory
body and industry and industry bodies
to make sure that those are fit for
purpose
and then an example from the us is the
radix program which is an nih initiative
to speed
specifically to speed innovation and
development and commercialization for
covert 19 testing so these are just some
examples
of initiatives that are
covered 19 pandemic specific and that
have emerged
in response to the pandemic
aimed at supporting the accelerated
development
of tests
what about manufacturing scale up
there are i know in in some countries
governments that are creating
coalitions of manufacturing companies
to support the early identification of
key blockers to achieving
mass scale up in manufacturer of
components so it's a again a
collaboration between governments
industry regulatory bodies and the
national health care systems to identify
what needs to be done what can be done
to
scale up and scale up quickly
what needs to be unblocked what
resources need to be deployed where they
can come from
identifying constraints and the
intention in the end is actually to
leave a legacy for
diagnostics infrastructure so the
increased manufacturing capacity
that will be developed in response to
the covert 19 pandemic
the intention is to leave this as a
legacy for the industry
moving forward so that that
infrastructure will continue to be
deployed
to serve a much stronger diagnostics
market and
diagnostics industry post covered 19.
governments are offering procurement of
test manufacturing equipment
as one option to do that quickly and
also the provision of
working capital largely in the form of
purchase orders
to help industry scale up
innovation um there the scale of this
particular opportunity
is driving a noticeable increase in
innovation
in the industry with many new technology
platforms
using the detection of the virus as a
proof of concept application
and then seeking collaborations to
commercialize the products
and there is a you know there's a need
for this
innovation there is a focus on point of
care platform so enabling
sars cough 2 testing to be taken outside
the laboratory
and into the community as i mentioned
you know there's enough demand there
for multiple solutions multiple
applications
and this is driving a lot of innovation
and there are specific competitions that
are funding this
so for example in the us we have the
example of the five million dollar
x prize which is a competition
specifically to develop
faster cheaper and easier to use cover
tests at scale
and in the uk there is a government
innovation fund
20 million pounds to do just the same
so what's the lasting impact of this on
the ivd
industry well there's definitely
already an increased awareness of
diagnostics
and in particular the value of
diagnostic testing particularly
in its uh ability to tackle
global health care crises another
example of a global health care crisis
is the emerging growth in antimicrobial
resistance
some governments as a result of this
want a stronger
home-based diagnostics industry and have
already stated their intention to
continue
supporting its development post covert
19.
so many of the assets and capabilities
that are developed to tackle the
pandemic
are expected to be continued in use
beyond covert 19 supporting a stronger
diagnostic testing market and a stronger
diagnostics industry
and one of the drivers for this is to
ensure that industry will be
pandemic ready so the next time
we will be able to respond much more
quickly to the next pandemic
so in general um the you know while the
covert 19 pandemic has been terrible for
society and our economies
it has provided an opportunity for the
diagnostics industry
to really emerge from the shadows of
other healthcare
markets and industries and to
demonstrate the value of diagnostic
testing
and will emerge from this pandemic
in a much stronger position than when it
um
when it went into it so thank you for
listening
and ready to take any questions
thank you david for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move to the live q a portion
of this presentation and as a reminder
to our audience members please submit
those questions
via the q a box so let's take a look
we already have some great questions
coming in
dave our first question is what has been
the most
surprising and satisfying development
over the past
nine months as a diagnostics industry
professional
you know it's very satisfying to the
tv in the morning of the national
national news and
actually and discussions
on diagnostic test sensitivity
specificity
used um different tests in different
environments
i mean that's you know as an almost
30-year veteran of the industry that has
never happened before
so diagnostic testing has become
mainstream
i think the value of diagnostic testing
is not acknowledged it was always
as i mentioned at the start of the
presentation you know it's typically
been undervalued and
and it's really hidden in the shadows
behind other
um other uh healthcare
um interventions therapeutics and uh and
and
med tech so that's um
that's that's great i mean it's it's
time has come and uh
that's that's been the most rewarding
and satisfying development
that's really come out of the coffin 19
pandemic
over the last nine nine months or so
thank you so much and you mentioned in
your presentation that
multiple testing solutions are required
to meet demand and the requirements
of different settings and use cases
what are your thoughts on what the mix
of different tests would look like
okay so there's okay so there's a lot of
um
a lot of different tests as people know
um you know the initial
the the pcr tests were the ones that
were developed the most quickly
and the you know the technology then you
collect as the technology lends itself
to a much more rapid development um than
some of the immunoassay approaches
um and they were deployed at quickly in
labs
and so pcr testing has been really the
predominant
testing platform that that has been used
up to now
it is also arguably the most accurate in
terms of its sensitivity and specificity
um and does a good job at identifying
people who are infected
and this there's been a big challenge in
scaling
scaling that up to test more people but
it's a difficult
it's difficult to scale it's difficult
to scale um for
various reasons one being that typically
the testing has been done in
laboratories
and so there's a you know relatively
slow turnaround time for the test
results
and it's quite a complex and um and
expensive process
so the you know while it's a good test
the the challenge has been getting more
people tested
um you know with the demand for testing
increasing you know
exponentially you know week by week
and the um acknowledged needs now to
test
as many people as possible uh that's not
going to be delivered
by uh by pcr it's just it's just too
difficult to scale up to those numbers
so we need alternative solutions um and
i as an example we have
um at the vector we're developing a
lateral flow antigen test
which um is a potential solution for
a different type of application so the
pcr test is good at
you know diagnosing people with copper
infection as our
as is the lateral flow test but in
addition because the lateral flow test
is
scalable and relatively um inexpensive
and affordable
and can produce a result quickly within
10 minutes
um it is a a solution that can be
deployed
to test the population mass testing
you know and even though it's widely
acknowledged that you know
lateral flow tests may not have the same
level of
performance and sensitivity as a pcr
test that
really doesn't matter so much when it's
been used
to enable society to get back to
whatever we call the new normal and
so you can imagine a lateral flow test
could be used quickly when someone is
about to enter a sports stadium or go to
work
um or get on a plane
um and that's that's very difficult
um to to do using using a
pcr test so there's you know there's lab
based pcr tests there's you know pcr has
also been moved
on to point of care platforms so it's
moving out of the lab into more
decentralized um
settings and then ultimately that
decentralization will will go all the
way to individuals to be able to test
themselves
and each of those applications requires
a different type of test
um but the volume will be in the uh
it will be in testing uh individuals
you know regularly to um enable them
to go back you know go back to
you know normal normal living and normal
life and uh
that's largely going to be through um
through lateral flow so
it's a combination they're all
complementary they all have their place
um and and all are required um but uh
yeah that's uh you know those lateral
flow tests are coming to market
and we'll see more of them being used
not to necessarily detect everyone
that's infected
but to detect the most infectious people
quickly and regularly
um which is the most effective way
really to get that r number down
thank you so much and what are your
thoughts about breathalyzers
to diagnose covid
breathalyzers okay um well i know there
are a number of
um breath tests in development
um uh yeah i mean if they
if they can be proved to work and work
effectively then
then then yeah that's another solution
that could um that could
add to the you know the the the the
the weapon the the the collection of
tests that
need to be deployed we need as many
tests as possible there's
there's space in this market for all
tests and all solutions
um i just you know as yet i just haven't
seen
any evidence yet on the on how well a
breath
test performs but if it if it shows the
requisite level of sensitivity and
specificity
um you know clearly it's a it's a it's a
sample type that could be
is is used it could be used in the
community so it could
you know ultimately lead to a community
use product
um so i i think you know theoretically
potentially yes great
um uh and hopefully some of these breast
breath breath tests will will come
through
thank you so much our next question from
our audience member and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
how can the industry be better prepared
for the next
pandemic
um okay so um
we're i mean the industry and not just
the industry yeah so the industry
collectively but the industry also
in collaboration with other stakeholders
governments
uh regulators um
the healthcare system itself funding
bodies you know everyone's
working very closely together very
engaged in trying to
find and rapidly find solutions to
uh meet the the testing demand at the
moment
and some of that some of those solutions
some of those assets that will be
developed through that process
um will continue um to be in place
uh to serve the diagnostics industry in
the future so
as an example uh the condor
program that i mentioned in my
presentation uh this is uh
this is where the the in the uk that the
government has
put together a network of organizations
that can facilitate
uh the clinical validation of tests
quickly
um that type of asset um can remain in
place
um so when we come out of covid and
we're back into
uh some some form of normality or
getting ready for the next pandemic
those sorts of assets that were put in
place to tackle the covet 19 pandemic
can
can work and help us um become better
prepared
uh for the next one so it's also about
learning how to
to do things more quickly and our
success
in in doing that these are all lessons
that the you know the industry can
can use to be better prepared and
actually we talk about the next pandemic
there are
other current global health care crises
where
diagnostic testing plays a critical role
and i think that's been recognized now
because of the role in covert 19 you
know for example the uh
the rapid increase in antimicrobial
resistance
and that's one where uh diagnostics play
a critical role so
you know i expect that um that the
industry will come out of
the covered 19 pandemic much stronger
also because governments now recognize
that a strong
diagnostics industry is a national
strategic asset
um and they have in the uk
they've they've they recognized that
what they thought was a relatively weak
diagnostics industry was one of the
reasons why
it took the country longer to respond um
and they um now realize the value of
having a stronger industry so that we're
we're better prepared
next time so there's a lot of you know
it's appreciating the value it's
building
um assets to enable the industry to to
work more rapidly and quickly with all
stakeholders
and having those um endure and beyond
this current pandemic i think all of
those things together will will lead to
a better
prepared industry in a better prepared
country
thank you so much we have time for a
couple of more questions when can the
united kingdom
expect the lfd rapid antigen test
um when can the united kingdom expect
that
okay so i i mean there there are a
number of
a number of tests in in development and
these tests are coming onto the market
in the uh in you know they're starting
to come on the market now
and coming onto the market in the in the
near future so um
the lateral flow antigen tests have been
um
later to market they're you know they're
more difficult to develop and take a
longer time than
say the pcr and the other molecular
tests just because of the nature of the
technology
and so um
in the uk there is also uh you know the
uk government have said that
they want a sovereign supply
so they are you know very focused on
utilizing a uk
manufactured test which is great for
companies in the uk that are developing
these tests
um so that's why they're working with us
uh closely to and you know to make sure
that happens as quickly as possible so
over the next few months um we'll start
to see those
those tests emerging and and getting
into use
thank you very much what's the time
scale
for abdica's antigen lft
to be readily available
uh well that's um i just need to refer
really to
our um our public statements
on that we are working very closely at
the moment with our partner saitiva
and our manufacturing partners um
to you know finalize the uh the the
design of the test so that it's
manufacturable at scale um to meet the
demand
um we will you know we will unlock
the uh um you know the specific
timelines on that
um as we normally do over
um you know the next few months as the
as the product passes through
that specific process
thank you so much our next question
is what is the biggest challenge to
scale up in the uk
for lfd lfds is it new tooling capacity
of existing kit
and are the supply chain issues or
possibly anything else
to be some of the challenges
um yeah
whoops it looks like we accidentally
lost him
i want to thank our audience for their
patience every once in a while we have a
little bit of a
technology issue and i'm sure that he
is going to hop right back in
okay i'm back um there he is
um i think i got the gist of that
question it was the you know what are
the key challenges to scale up
manufacturing
yes is it the kit or or something else
um
well i mean we uh at a factor we are
we're not we're not a manufacturer we're
a test developer
um so uh the but from our understanding
of
working closely with our manufacturing
partners it's
um it's yeah it's it's how do you scale
up
how do you increase the the
manufacturing capacity it's either
through
um putting in place additional
automated manufacturing uh lines um or
you can scale up you know more manually
and that would just that's a matter of
employing
you know more people um to do manual um
assemblies and so forth
it's largely um the kit is the
availability of the manufacturing kit
um you know you have to manufacture the
manufacturing kit
um so there's a timeline attached to
that and
this kit you know it's very specific for
a lateral flow test it's a very specific
piece of kit
and kits and you know the competition
for this from around the world is
intense
um so that's really the limiting
um factor however um
you know with the involvement of of um
of governments
and who can procure this stuff um
probably more quickly
than individual companies representing
their national industries i think we can
uh
we can address that problem somewhat by
trying to
to get that kit developed and brought
online as quickly as possible but that's
that's it again it goes back to the
comments i made on supply chain
um you know we have we have
tests being manufactured but there's a
lot of stuff behind that all the
components
you know they have to be manufactured as
well and so it's not just the
the capacity to to develop the test
itself there's a
there's a whole tale behind that of um
of manufacturing scale-up challenges but
for the lateral flow test it's
it's specific the kit and there is a
there is a big effort ongoing at the
moment to address that
thank you so much david we're out of
time but i just wanted to offer you an
opportunity to provide some closing
remarks before we go and remind the
audience members that
any questions not answered today will be
answered via email
would you like to have some closing
remarks
uh sure i i just hope that um
you know in this in the short time that
we've had i'm i've you know at least
uh highlighted some of the uh you know
the the pluses and minuses of for the
for the industry
in um in in in this this come out of
this pan
this particular pandemic you know
there's it's been a great
opportunity for the industry to
highlight what it can do
it can highlight the value of the of the
test that it develops
and also it's uh it's brought it out of
the shadows and governments now
see it as a national strategic asset so
that's all very positive and that's all
something which will endure
beyond this and into the future um
there have been very very significant
challenges uh the nature of competition
has changed
um but the but the industry has
responded
you know ex extremely positively despite
all of that and
we are you know getting all those tasks
on the market that
that are required um the next big
challenge is you know can we get enough
of them um to market
in uh in the short time frame
david thank you again for your
presentation today and for your
important research
and i want to thank our audience for
their outstanding questions
and this presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing for 12
months so please remember to share it
with your colleagues who may have been
interested in today's topic but missed
the presentation
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda
tab at the auditorium for a full listing
thanks again for participation until
next time stay
healthy stay safe take care everyone
bye-bye
thank you bye